[MUSIC - GERSHWIN, " 'S
WONDERFUL"]
WILL BURTON: What the hell
are you guys doing in my song?
MAX VON ESSEN: It's my song!
ROBERT FAIRCHILD: We'd
almost be in love!
[MUSIC - GERSHWIN, " 'S
WONDERFUL"]
[MUSIC - GERSHWIN, "WHO CARES?"]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you all
for being here at Google today.
We really appreciate it.
Can you just take a minute
and introduce yourselves,
and tell us your
character names,
and everything like that?
And if you're a director,
say that kind of thing well.
MAX VON ESSEN: Sure.
I'm Max Von Essen.
I play Henri Baurel
in the show, who
is part of a love
triangle of three men, who
are all in love
with the same woman,
or think they're in love
or want similar things.
And he's actually only one
the main French characters
in the show.
So I'm a French
guy, kind of torn,
I know I'm in love with
Lise, played by-- well,
she'll tell you.
I'm kind of torn.
I desperately want
to be a performer
and move to the United
States, and go to New York,
and be a performer, perform
at Radio City Music Hall.
But I know what my parents are
sort of gearing me up towards,
taking over for the
family business.
So he's very torn in his life.
Torn as far as his
relationship with Lise,
and his life in
general, as to what
he feels he should
be doing, what
his passion is to be doing.
LEANNE COPE: [INAUDIBLE]
MAX VON ESSEN: I'm not sure.
LEANNE COPE: OK.
Can you hear that?
I'm Leanne Cope, and
I play Lise Dassin.
She is the lucky
lady who has three
men fall in love with her.
She's a young girl who, she's
actually Jewish, and was
hidden by the Baurel family
during the Second World
War in Paris.
So she comes out of hiding,
and she bumps into Jerry,
who is kind of an instant,
love-at-first-sight thing.
But she is also engaged to
Henri, so she's very torn.
But there's a happy
ending in the end.
I think, happy for
everyone in the end.
Everyone figures out where
they should be going in life.
So yeah, I play Lise Dassin.
WILL BURTON: I'm Will Burton.
I am playing Adam
Hochberg today.
I'm actually an understudy.
I cover him as
well, on some days.
But Adam Hochberg is a
Jewish-American soldier
who fought in World War II,
and decided, afterwards,
to stay in Paris, and
pursue his writing career.
He's a composer.
So he's decided to stay
in Paris to be inspired.
And his muse becomes Lise.
He falls in love with Lise.
And he meets these
two gentlemen,
and they all become
buds, and that's
kind of Adam's part to play.
ROBERT FAIRCHILD:
I'm Robert Fairchild.
I play Jerry Mulligan, the
role made famous by Gene Kelly.
And he's a soldier
in World War II
who stays in Paris on
the GI Bill to study art,
and falls in love
with Lise, and becomes
best friends with these guys.
CHRISTOPHER WHEELDON:
I'm Christopher Wheeldon,
the director choreographer
of "American in Paris."
Thank you.
I play this guy who is
happily choreographing
in the ballet world, when
one day, a big Broadway
producer came
along and said, hey
do you want to direct
a Broadway musical?
And I said, sure, why not?
Let's have a go.
That's my role.
And I just-- sorry, Jill.
I just want to say, Will's
actually making his debut
tonight as Adam Hochberg.
JILL PAICE: My
name is Jill Paice.
I play Milo Davenport, who,
apparently, nobody loves.
Thanks.
CHRISTOPHER WHEELDON:
We love you.
JILL PAICE: I'll take these two.
She is a rich
American heiress, who
arrives in Paris right at
the height of the new, sort
of, art scene that's coming up.
And she chases this guy
for most of the show,
but also commissions
a ballet, which
will star Lise, that Jerry
will do the set design for,
and Adam will write
the music for.
So I think I'm very important.
And I love me.
STUART OKEN: At the end
of the show, anyway.
JILL PAICE: Yes.
STUART OKEN: Hi,
I'm Stuart Oken.
I get to play producer.
I had the great good fortune
to be offered a chance
to conceive of how
we might approach
bringing "An American in Paris"
to Broadway, which had never
been.
It had only been this 1950 movie
that had been quite famous,
but had never found
its way to Broadway.
And it was a bit
of a dated movie,
although there were lots
of wonderful things in it.
So along with Chris and Rob
Fisher, our musical supervisor,
and Craig Lucas, our book
writer, and of course,
with the magnificent George
and Ira Gershwin songs
to work with, we
had the good fortune
to be able to spend the five
years it took to realize
Chris's vision, with Bob
Crowley, and Natasha Katz,
and his wonderful
team of designers,
and then to have this amazing
company bring it to life.
So we've had a
wonderful journey.
And I'm proud to be here.
Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm going
to fall off this chair.
MAX VON ESSEN: Are you OK?
FEMALE SPEAKER: I really am.
I don't usually wear heels.
I don't know if you've bumped
into me around the office,
but this is a special occasion.
It's not working
out so well for me.
So yes, you're here.
You're playing at the Palace
Theater now, but you opened,
your world premiere was
in Paris, France, correct?
Can you tell us a
little bit about that,
how that came to be?
STUART OKEN: That
usually comes back to me.
I'll tell you a little,
and they can tell you
what it was like to be there.
You know, "American
in Paris," right?
So you always have
to go somewhere.
If you do a new musical--
and we are a new musical,
even though it feels
like maybe it's
not-- the first time it's
on stage, different script,
different song order, different
people, different character
conceptions, it's new, and
it takes you a lot of time.
This is very different
than a revival, which
you can kind of rehearse
and do, because you're not
rewriting every day.
Anyway, we needed to go
somewhere to work on the show,
to, so to speak,
get the kinks out,
but to really get our rhythm.
And we had to pick
a place to go.
And there was a wonderful
producer in Paris,
his name is Jean-Luc Choplin.
And Jean-Luc, who I
oddly happened to know,
because we both spent 10 years
working at Disney between '93,
I think, and 2004.
And Jean-Luc has become
the artistic director
of this exquisite theater, a
historic, beautiful building
called Theatre du Chatelet.
And France does not
have much of a history
of doing American musicals.
It's actually one of the
countries in the world
where we just haven't
resonated with this very
unique American art form.
But Jean-Luc started bringing
productions in English
that he'd put together.
He'd only run them two or
three weeks at the most,
but he'd bring in wonderful
performers and artists
mostly from England,
because you do something
in the original--
he only performs
in the original language.
So he was developing an
audience for American musicals,
and he did the classics.
He did Sondheim.
He did Rodgers and Hammerstein.
He did Lerner and Loewe.
And after about six,
seven years of doing that,
he thought that it possibly
was the time for his audiences
to actually have a
brand new musical.
But this seemed like a
rather safe one, because it
had familiarity to them.
The story had empathy
for French characters,
and the music was so well known.
So fortunately, serendipitously,
we managed to come together.
And we rehearsed in America.
It was our production
here in America
that was all put together.
And then all of it
went over to Paris,
where the scenery
was all built there,
the costumes were
all built there.
And our whole company,
like 75 of us,
lived in Paris for
3 and 1/2 months,
and not only got
to make our show,
but got to experience
the beauty and the joy
of being in a location together,
and building the authenticity
inside of our company.
So that's how it happened.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That sounds
absolutely fantastic.
Now, some of you are from
New York, some of you
are from elsewhere.
Leanne, I know that you're
actually from England,
and you were in the Royal
Ballet, is that correct?
LEANNE COPE: Yeah, I'm from
a small town called Bath.
Whenever I say that
here, they're like, what?
You were born in a bath?
Don't worry.
It's a small town
southwest of London.
But I moved to London when I
was 11 and studied at the Royal
Ballet School, and then
danced with the Royal Ballet
Company for 12 years.
So ballet is silent art
form, so to suddenly,
after 12 years of performing
on stage, to suddenly have
to open my mouth
and speak and sing
has been terrifying, but
liberating and amazing.
So yeah, this is kind the
first venture into spoken word.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Right.
And it's your first
venture as well, correct?
ROBERT FAIRCHILD: Yeah, I danced
with the New York City Ballet
in Lincoln Center, and I've
been there for 10 years.
And that's how we met, actually.
I've been in a lot of his
ballets at the company.
And he asked me, can you sing?
After we did some gala
where I was tap dancing.
And I said yeah, I think so.
And that's kind of how this
whole collaboration started
between the two of us.
And it's so liberating to
be on stage telling stories
for 10 years, without
opening your mouth,
and then to get the opportunity
to speak, and sing, and dance
all at the same time.
It's just the
coolest opportunity.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Can you tell us
a little bit about the audition
process?
Because compared to the
sort of rock and roll,
heavy movement shows
that have become
popularized in
recent years, this
is kind of a throwback to the
very classic days of Broadway.
The big sweeping dance
numbers, it's beautiful.
CHRISTOPHER WHEELDON: Well,
the audition process was tough.
There are many reasons to do "An
American in Paris," of course.
The great music of
George and Ira Gershwin,
the phenomenal setting.
But I think we all agreed
that unless we really
found the cast that could handle
the dance in the show, really
embody these characters,
and not just be-- there's
a history of ballet dancers
having been on Broadway,
and there tends to be a little
bit of a sort of, oh, you know,
great dancers, but shame they
can't really sing or act.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Right.
CHRISTOPHER WHEELDON:
So we really wanted
to find true triple threats.
I actually call Leanne
a quadruple threat,
because a triple threat is a
singer, an actor, and a dancer.
But she also has to be a
ballet dancer, on pointe, which
is a very specialized skill.
So it made the search for
Lise particularly challenging.
And I also work with
the Royal Ballet a lot.
I'm artistic associate there.
And so I've known Leanne
since she was in the school.
And we actually grew
up in the same county.
I was born about an hour away
from where Leanne was born.
But I didn't know her
at that age, though.
So somebody said,
we were searching,
we were looking in London.
We had an extensive
audition search
all across the United States.
And somebody said,
oh, well you know,
Leanne Cope actually sung
once in the music competition.
And she's got kind
of a nice voice.
So I grabbed her between
two shows of Swan Lake.
There was a matinee and
an evening of Swan Lake.
She still had her
feathers in her hair.
And I kind of managed
to sort of bully her
into the dressing room.
Because she said-- I said to
her, so I hear you can sing.
And she's like, yeah, but
I only sing in the shower.
So I'm like, OK, well,
get in the shower.
So I kind of plopped
her in there,
and she knew "The Man I
Love," and she sang "The Man
I Love," and it was very
clear in that moment
that this was somebody
who really could sing.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Right.
Was that a little
nerve wracking for you?
LEANNE COPE: It was terrifying.
Because I hadn't had
any singing lessons--
I used to sing in the choir at
school, and at the Royal Ballet
School, it was compulsory to
take another musical instrument
or to sing.
So I tried piano for a year.
I was terrible.
I tried flute.
So I thought, OK,
let's just try singing.
And I really enjoyed it.
But yeah, as I hadn't
sang in front of anyone
for a very long time,
that was terrifying.
But now, after having
200 shows under my belt,
it's not so bad to have to
sing in front of you guys.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Right.
Well, and I did not look
up anything about the show.
I knew nothing about anybody
before I went to see it.
And afterwards,
when they told me
that this was your first time
singing, and your first time
singing, I was blown away.
I never would have guessed,
in a million years.
It really was incredible.
And I mean, I'm sorry that
I'm gushing a little bit here.
But the dance, the
choreography was beautiful.
When you were
writing this version
of the show, the
show for the stage,
how did you decide what kind
of dance was going to go where,
and how to
incorporate the ballet
in a way that made sense?
STUART OKEN: Let me say
something before Chris
answers most of that question.
The movie, among all the
things it's known for,
it's known for this
how-many-minute ballet,
15-minute ballet at
the end of the movie.
Famous.
Never been done.
I think if it won
the Academy Award,
it won it almost
for that reason.
It was revolutionary.
And when I was thinking about
how to do this, when they said,
do you want to do this, I
said, if we don't run straight
toward the ballet, instead of
being afraid of the ballet,
we can never possibly succeed.
Because our goal is to have
an audience, even if they
don't know the
movie, come in and be
surprised about what they see.
But to be surprised, you've
got to see world class ballet.
And you needed to have ballet
not just be at the very end,
but be the language of the show.
And honestly, it was the
most terrifying thing of all,
because who could do that?
I mean, the people you
could point to and say,
that person could direct this,
that person could make this.
Because I didn't want
just a choreographer.
I wanted someone who'd
conceive the show
in the language of movement.
And without Christopher,
there'd be no show.
And without people like
Robbie, and Leanne,
and the other people that
have those quadruple ,
skills we wouldn't have been
able to lift the show to where
it is.
So that was in our heads.
Now how he figured
out what to do,
you can talk about
how you saw dance,
but that's how
Christopher's here,
and that's how the
show has come to exist.
CHRISTOPHER WHEELDON: Well,
I think as Stuart said,
we wanted our story to drive
straight through to the ballet,
and then continue
through the ballet.
Because in the movie, the
ballet at the end of the movie
is kind of a voyage through--
a sort of postcard voyage,
in a way, through Paris.
A sort of chase.
And the ballet at
the end of our show
is the crashing together
of the various art forms
that our characters are
developing in Paris.
So Adam's composition,
Jerry's set design.
And that idea actually
came kind of late.
Jerry is the set designer,
and Lise, of course,
as the ballerina, Milo
as the benefactress.
So even though the ballet
kind of sits almost
as an abstract piece of dance,
with a very sensual pas de deux
at the heart of it.
So the story of the ballet, in
a way, is the romantic climax,
I suppose, of the coming
together of Jerry and Lise.
But around it, the framework
is fairly abstract.
Inspired by the art
of Mondrian, that's
where Jerry's art kind of goes.
At the beginning of
the show, the design
sort of captures some
of the more, sort of,
figurative sketches of his work.
And you can also
track his development
and his inspiration,
the inspiration
he gets from the artists
of the time in Paris.
But you know, it was daunting.
The ballet was daunting.
Because as Stuart said,
it's really, aside
from the great performances,
the one thing that
really makes the movie special.
And we wanted it to be very
much the heart of this piece.
And then, of course, how
do you get an audience
to really believe in that?
Especially, perhaps, people that
may be intimidated by ballet,
or have never been
to the ballet before,
or may think, oh, god,
that sounds boring.
So we begin the show with
a seven minute ballet.
And so it's kind of like, this
is what you're in for, folks.
But it's very much-- there
are three ballets in the show.
There's the opening
ballet, which
is very descriptive
of Paris emerging
from this terrible, dark
period of occupation.
So you get these
kind of shifting,
this sort of
ever-shifting panorama
of streets with bread lines, a
collaborator being flushed out.
It's very dark.
But it moves quickly.
It's quite cinematic, in a way.
Then the middle
ballet closes at one,
and it very much sort of
tells a fast-forward story
of Jerry and Milo, Milo sort
of wooing Jerry, and taking him
around Paris,
supporting his art.
Lise rehearsing the ballet.
Jerry and Lise kind of
meeting secretly at the Seine,
and then Jerry going
to a bar with Milo,
and it sort of, in
a way, it kind of
ties up all of the
stories that we've
been following through Act I.
And it's very colorful, in
contrast to the first ballet,
which is quite dark.
It's very colorful and
dynamic, and exciting.
And it's a great piece of music.
The Second Rhapsody
for Piano and Orchestra
by George Gershwin.
Everybody knows the
Rhapsody in Blue,
but very few people know this
fantastic second rhapsody
that he wrote.
And then, of course, the
final ballet, which I
already described.
And then, in between,
there's a big tap number,
there's a fantastic Broadway
style number, fantasy number
the Gallery Lafayette.
So our show lives and breathes
with different dance forms.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Right, and
I'd love to talk about that.
It feels like there's not five
minutes that goes by where
you guys aren't dancing.
It's multiple shows every week.
And I see people switching
between character shoes,
and pointe shoes, and tap
shoes, and lots and lots
of costume changes as well.
Now, was that difficult,
having to switch
between all these
different mediums of dance?
And with the costume
changes, and mic pacs.
Did you have to dance
with the mic pacs on?
LEANNE COPE: My mic
pac's in my wig.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh!
How did they-- I'm just
going to accept that.
Okay.
LEANNE COPE: Yeah, it's amazing.
CHRISTOPHER WHEELDON:
It's actually
embedded into her skull.
LEANNE COPE: Now I
have a flat head.
ROBERT FAIRCHILD: It's
actually really funny,
because there's this moment
in the pas de deux, where
I come up behind
her, and there's
this kind of caressing moment.
And sometimes my cheek
hits this battery pack.
I'm like, she's a robot!
It's so weird.
Anyway.
LEANNE COPE: I found, I'd
never danced in heels before.
Now I love wearing them.
But the transition from
pointe shoes to heels,
throughout the show,
is quite difficult,
just for your calves, mainly.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Right.
No, I know.
LEANNE COPE: And the
girls that have to tap,
as well, I don't know
how they do that.
I'm lucky I didn't
have to do it.
Well, I couldn't.
I can't tap dance.
But the girls that
go from pointe shoes,
to character shoes, to
tap shoes, and walk up
flights of stairs.
MAX VON ESSEN: It's also
crazy with the amount of time
we have, which for some people,
at certain times, is seconds.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Right.
MAX VON ESSEN: And I mean you
run off-- I'm obviously, well,
not obviously, but I don't
dance very much in the show,
and I don't have to switch
between all kinds of shoes
and stuff, but a
lot of people do.
But I do have some quick
changes, as we all do.
And it was crazy, because
we obviously tried out
the show in Paris.
And the crew, very few people
on the crew spoke English.
So here, imagine now, you have
16 seconds for a quick change.
You're trying to say, what
are your pants, the order,
and your shoes, what
needs to happen,
and your mic pack,
and all these things.
And then you kind of
get into a groove.
But in Paris, in
France in general,
things are very different,
and work laws and everything.
Two days later, we'd have a
completely different crew.
It's not like New York, where
your dresser is your dresser.
So you were like, oh, good,
now I got the quick change.
Then you'd run off
stage two nights later,
you're like, who are you?
Who is this person who's
pulling down my pants right now?
Hang on, I've not
ever said that before.
No, but it really
was-- no, but it really
was a crazy experience.
And I always find
it so fascinating.
I wish you could bring
a friend, or like,
I wish my mom could come
backstage and watch from
the wings, because
that is really what's--
LEANNE COPE: More going
on offstage than on.
MAX VON ESSEN: Yeah,
it's so complex.
And we have very little
space, especially
here in New York, in
the Broadway theater.
And it's such a choreographed
ballet back behind the scenes,
as well.
So there are a lot
of quick changes,
and there are a lot of going
in and out of different shoes.
And it's pretty incredible
what's happening backstage.
I really wish people
could see it sometime.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Well, it's
incredible from the audience's
perspective, as well.
At least for me,
because I'm watching,
I think during the ballet,
you're wearing a yellow dress,
then you switch to
a different dress,
and then you're back in the
yellow dress, and I'm like,
wait, she just ducked down!
What happened?
It was literally magic.
MAX VON ESSEN: Velcro.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That's
how it appeared.
MAX VON ESSEN: Velcro.
Velcro.
LEANNE COPE: Though that
originally wasn't in the plan.
I was originally
in the yellow dress
for the whole of the ballet.
But we got to the pas de deux,
and I heard that orchestra,
and I thought, I don't think
this pas de deux is yellow.
For me it didn't.
And I think I just didn't
feel like that music said
yellow to me.
But they came up with this other
costume, and I think it works.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I think it does.
Really, I thought
that it-- I don't
want to give it away if
you haven't gone to see it,
because you should,
but no, I thought
that it worked very, very well.
I know exactly
what you're saying.
LEANNE COPE: And
when she is-- there's
a moment where
she's in her head,
and she's thinking
she's with Jerry,
and that's when she's
wearing one costume,
and then when she's actually in
the ballet, she's in the other.
So it kind of makes
sense to have the change.
But yeah, that took a
lot of workshopping,
that costume change.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
It was impressive.
So let's talk for a second
about the ensemble, if we could.
So you are-- I
learned a word today.
It's called track.
I guess it's a phrase.
I don't know.
I learned a thing.
I'm learning new things
every day here at Google.
So explain to me and to
everyone else, what is a track,
and what does that mean for a
person who's in the ensemble?
WILL BURTON: You know, a
track's difficult to explain,
and we as actors, when
we're trying to tell people
about our job, use the word like
everyone knows what it means,
but most people outside theater
don't know what it means.
And so what it is, as
an ensemble member,
I think it-- I play a
bunch of different parts
as the show goes on.
And that route through
the show is my track.
So there are people who, just
like I cover Max and I cover
Brandon, the guy who
was supposed to be here,
their tracks, I
know exactly what
they do throughout
the show, including
all the backstage
choreography, to make
sure I don't get hit
by anything that's
flying in and out of the wings.
So a track just describes my
route from the top of the show
to the end of the show.
And there are, I guess,
four other people
in the show that know my track.
And we have swings
who are offstage,
who don't do the
show every night,
who know multiple, like
four, five, six tracks,
so that on any given night, if
someone's in, someone's out,
this person can go
into this track.
If he's out, I go
into his track,
another guy goes into my track.
So that's the
meaning of the word.
MAX VON ESSEN: Is that
how it became swing?
Like, you swing into a track?
Do you guys know?
Is that why you
call them a swing?
FEMALE SPEAKER: I was
just going to ask that,
because that's another word.
MAX VON ESSEN: Swing is an
offstage ensemble member,
who's a swing, and covers, like
Will said, five, six, seven--
and we have swings now who
are learning even more,
because it's a difficult show.
And there injuries, or
people just get sick,
and you need a night off.
And we've had a lot of
people swinging in and out
of the show, because
it is a difficult show
for the ensemble.
WILL BURTON: And that
job, I have to say,
really is truly incredible.
Because in this
show in particular,
the tracks are very complex,
because we, as the ensemble,
we're moving a lot of the sets
into place and out of place,
and there's little
spikes on the stage
everywhere for all
of our little things,
and we have these big screens
that are projected onto,
like perfectly projected
onto these screens,
so if they're not
in the right place,
the projections are
all whacked out.
So the swings, their job is
just insanely complicated,
and I don't know how they
do it as well as they do.
But we have amazing swings.
JILL PAICE: We call
them the Navy SEALs.
STUART OKEN: Our
company on stage is 25,
but our company is 35.
So what the audience
doesn't necessarily know
is that we really
do need 35 people
to be able to do a show with
25 people, eight times a week,
for an extended period of time.
So we're all part
of the same company,
but different people
do different things.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK.
Well, I'm going
to touch on that.
Just to remind
everybody, there's
microphones on
either aisle here.
If you have any questions,
feel free to line up over there
and we'll give you a point
when it's your turn to talk.
So speaking of that, you have
this very, very large Broadway
family.
While I was hanging out
with you guys before,
you were telling me
about birthday cakes,
and how everyone buys
each other birthday cakes.
Do you have any fun
backstage stories
that you could share with us?
MAX VON ESSEN: [INAUDIBLE]
JILL PAICE: I never go!
ROBERT FAIRCHILD:
You hosted one!
JILL PAICE: I hosted one.
Yeah, we do.
I think similar to
probably how you guys have
these kinds of
things, we do what's
called SNOB, which is
Saturday Night On Broadway.
And after the second show, we
will stay after and maybe have
drinks and pizza, and we
even had one of our producers
host the most amazing sort
of southern comfort food one.
And it's just a chance
for us to sort of unwind.
Yes, we still have a
matinee the next day,
but it sort of gives you
something to look forward to.
Like you'll be on stage in the
middle of a costume change,
and you'll be like, vodka!
It'll get you through.
WILL BURTON: Our
day off is Monday.
So that's why it's
Saturday night.
Our day off is Monday, and so
we just have one show Sunday,
but by the second
show on Saturday,
generally we're pretty tired.
So that's why SNOB exists.
MAX VON ESSEN: I do
remember, in Paris, too,
we had a lot of
space in the wings,
which is very rare on Broadway.
We don't have it here.
But the Parisian
crew, they would like,
they got so into it.
They learned the choreography.
They would dance along.
While we be in a
number on stage,
you'd see them in the
wings, dancing along.
We don't have that
kind of space here,
and also, the New York
crew is a little different.
I don't imagine these
guys dancing along.
ROBERT FAIRCHILD:
That's not true.
MAX VON ESSEN: Really?
ROBERT FAIRCHILD: Oh,
Stairway To Paradise.
MAX VON ESSEN: Tell me!
ROBERT FAIRCHILD: We
have this new stage
manager, her name's Julia.
And she's just in between
all the furniture backstage,
just doing this
interpretive dancing.
It's pretty-- it's a sight.
STUART OKEN: She's amazing.
She's a lot of fun.
CHRISTOPHER WHEELDON: I
actually only met her.
She'd been on the
show for a while,
because I was away
over the summer.
Because as the director,
you do actually
end up suffering serious
FOMO, because you
get so attached to your
family, and you build the show,
and you really are Big Daddy,
you're taking care of everyone,
and making sure
that they're giving
a good-- a great performance.
And then you leave.
And they all get to
stay behind and have
Saturday Night On Broadway.
And I follow it on
Facebook from afar.
But the first time I
met Julia, I came back,
and I walked into the
office, and she just
goes, what have you done?
And I wasn't sure
whether that was
a good thing or a bad thing.
And then she launched into, this
is the most amazingly complex
show that I've ever worked on.
Because really, for the
crew and the stage manager,
the calling of the show
is a feat of virtuosity.
I mean, every cue has to be
absolutely bang on, mostly
for safety.
I mean, we have so much scenery
in our show, and most of it
moves around on deck.
Traditionally, Broadway
shows have a lot of tracks,
and trucks that kind of
track on, and track off.
MAX VON ESSEN: Different tracks.
CHRISTOPHER WHEELDON:
Different kind.
MAX VON ESSEN: Like
an actual track.
CHRISTOPHER WHEELDON:
Like a railroad track.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you
for qualifying that for me.
CHRISTOPHER WHEELDON: Our
show, one of the reasons
why it feels so dancey is
because the scenery dances
as well.
I mean, the side
walls of the building
are where the wings-- where
the side stage space ends.
And the back wall, you know,
our BP, our back plastic,
which is the backdrop, is
right up against the back wall.
So there's very,
very little space
in the wings for
all of the scenery,
and it gets-- so
it comes offstage,
it gets hooked on
to the big chains,
and then winched up so that
other pieces can come in.
Meanwhile, you've got
dancers and actors
zipping around and
changing costumes.
So their job, I think,
is highly stressful.
It's sort of like NASA mission
control back there every night.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Well,
it looks like we
have a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you
so much for being here.
As a native New Yorker,
it's so exciting for me
to get front row seats to a
Broadway show, so thank you.
So I'm really curious
about the underlying story.
It seems to be a little bit in
the background of World War II,
and the Jewish female
who comes out of hiding.
So I'm curious, maybe,
how was that received back
when it was a movie decades ago,
versus how it was received now,
both in, maybe, the
States or in Paris.
I'm also curious if any of you
did any reflection or studies
to relate to that
period of time,
and maybe for the
character, I forget
the character's name, but the
Jewish female who comes out
of hiding.
And lastly, if anybody
ever reached out to you
to share their story, or to say,
wow, this really spoke to me,
or it was difficult for me
to watch this, or just really
curious about that story line.
MAX VON ESSEN: Chris, do
want to tell them first
how you went from the
movie, and updated the--
CHRISTOPHER WHEELDON:
Sure, yeah sure.
So, I mean, the movie touches
on and suggests that this
is right after the war.
But in 1952, I
think it was, well,
it was obviously still very
raw, and very difficult
to place it into a rich and
realistic historical context.
So one of the things that was,
I think, appealing to Craig
Lucas, our writer, when we
were approached to do this,
and we all agreed that there was
no point in trying to recreate
this beautiful movie on stage.
It was a moment in time,
and it is what it is,
and the stars were the
great stars of their time,
and it was our
responsibility to find
the new great stars of
our time, and to perhaps
place this story in a
more accurate historical--
within a more accurate
historical context.
So Craig took it back to sort
of the eve of the liberation,
or just after the
liberation of Paris.
And I think he really relished
in the opportunity to flesh
out these characters.
It's still sort of a similar
structure, a character
structure, as the movie.
But obviously, when
dealing with Lise Dassin,
Lise Dassin in
our production has
been in hiding for the
duration of the occupation,
and the show opens,
really, with her first day
back out on the
streets of Paris.
STUART OKEN: It's worth saying,
she wasn't Jewish in the movie.
CHRISTOPHER
WHEELDON: She wasn't.
STUART OKEN: So that
was something that--
AUDIENCE: The character wasn't?
STUART OKEN: The character
was not Jewish in the movie.
CHRISTOPHER WHEELDON:
It was suggested
that she was in hiding, but
because her parents were
in the resistance.
STUART OKEN: That's right.
AUDIENCE: Oh, fascinating.
CHRISTOPHER WHEELDON:
Yeah, it was.
We were able to go a
lot further with that.
STUART OKEN: There's
some belief, I think,
that in 1950, when they made
the movie, some of these--
it was a little too
close to the war.
And there's so much there that
suggests something deeper,
but they stayed away from it.
So Craig making the
choice to say, well, let's
just put her there.
Now she's got a reason
for living in hiding.
Now there's secrets
that can't be exposed,
so when Jerry learns
about her history,
everything makes sense.
But he doesn't know about
her, and those are things
that really were differences.
The big one is, you
said, moving from 1950
to the moment the war ended.
So the impact on every character
really is the war, right?
It's about a lot of people
coming out of a very dark time,
and actually, you
said this earlier,
I think, Leanne,
or somebody did,
that eventually, everyone
develops a sense of empathy
for everybody else.
They kind of get why they're all
in this place at the same time.
And the right things do happen.
But there's a lot of confusion
when you come out of a war.
JILL PAICE: And I
think for us as actors,
getting to live in Paris for
two months, and so much of Paris
is preserved as it
was back in that time.
So to see the very locations,
the Galleries Lafayette,
the Ritz, Montmartre, things
that we reference in our show,
to go and see them.
We also happened to be there
when the Musee Carnavalet was
doing this amazing photography
exhibit on the liberation
and on the resistance fighters.
So we all went, all of us,
and spent a day there, sort
of absorbing this experience.
And I think more than
anything, being there
made sure that we didn't make a
character of their experience.
So it became very real to us.
And we were very well received
by the French audiences, which,
we weren't sure when we went
there what it would be like.
And our first sort of
run through in front
of an invited audience was
flabbergasting, because they
were on their feet.
And you look over, and the crew
were clapping in the wings.
And we just felt so
embraced by this culture
and by these people.
I have a real
affection for them now.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
A question over here?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I loved this show.
It was one of my favorite
shows I've ever seen.
And I also love the ballet.
I actually was at Lincoln
Center last night.
And I really care about
the ballet as an art form,
and I care about the fact
that the audience is aging.
And one of my hopes
for the show would
be, seeing how
popular it is, and it
won the Tony, is that it can
expand the exposure that ballet
is getting with the
general population,
and perhaps raise the profile
and attendance of the ballet.
And I just wonder
if that's something
you guys have talked about,
if you planned for that,
if there's anything.
CHRISTOPHER WHEELDON:
I think, I mean,
it was certainly a
very attractive reason
to do this show, for me,
was to put some real ballet
on Broadway, and put
it out for an audience
that perhaps hasn't had the
opportunity to go to the ballet
before, or as I said
before, may have
some sort of preconceived
notion that it's
stuffy or old fashioned.
I have to say that for
me, the joy and confidence
that I get from
hearing the biggest
ovation of the
night, every night,
on Broadway, for a non-ballet
audience, be for the ballet,
and hear the comments of
the audience as they leave.
Sometimes I lurk,
which can be dangerous,
because sometimes you
hear bad things, too.
But hearing people
say, oh, you know,
I didn't know ballet
could be that exciting.
Or just having notes
left for me saying,
we're really excited to come see
you work at the New York City
Ballet, or go see the ballet
at American Ballet Theater.
It's really encouraging.
And I think we're lucky.
I think we're part
of a generation where
the audience for ballet
is being reinvigorated.
There are, now,
young choreographers
who are excited about
making dynamic ballet again.
And ballet that focuses
on the human condition
and a connection between people.
It went through a period of
this sort of intensely physical,
it became very much about
what the body could do.
And now I think
it's veering back
towards a more narrative base,
which is very, very exciting.
And particularly
here in New York,
I think [? our ballet ?]
incentive
has a lot of really, really
exciting new work going on.
AUDIENCE: It would
be neat if there
was a promotion for the ballet,
for the audience as they
leave your show or something.
CHRISTOPHER WHEELDON: Yeah.
LEANNE COPE: We were at
the Broadway flea market
the other day, and
this guy came up.
We were signing posters, and
this guy came up, and was like,
I hate ballet, I hate opera.
And I just didn't know
what he was going to say.
He was quite scary, the
way he came up to us.
ROBERT FAIRCHILD: I hate opera.
I hate classical everything.
LEANNE COPE: But
I love your show.
And we're like,
oh, thank goodness.
But like Chris said, at
the end of the ballet,
I still, every
night, kind of feel
very emotional that the audience
is receiving ballet that way.
And I genuinely do think
that people are like,
oh, OK, I can give
this a go now.
Maybe I will take a trip
up to Lincoln Center.
And vice versa, because I think
maybe a ballet fan wouldn't
necessarily come
and see a musical,
because they might
think it's not for them.
But then, knowing that
it's Christopher Wheeldon
choreography, they'll
come down to see the show,
and then they'll want
to see more musicals.
So I think it works
both ways, actually.
I'm hoping it will.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I think
we have time for one more.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My question is also about
ballet, and specifically
for Christopher and Robert.
I'm a subscriber at
the NYCB, and I've
been familiar with
your work for years.
And I'd love to hear you
talk a little bit about
how your experiences
with the NYCB
informed your work
with the show,
and maybe what the
differences and the challenges
are that you face
working in pure ballet,
versus a Broadway show.
CHRISTOPHER WHEELDON: Well,
actually, it's interesting.
I think my experiences working
with the New York City Ballet
as a dancer and a choreographer,
and also with the Royal Ballet,
in our show, for me, it's
almost the coming together
of my two balletic
worlds, my upbringing,
my training in London, in
sort of a more narrative based
works.
You know, the Royal Ballet
are famous for the big story
ballets.
And for such a small
country, we actually
had two of the great, great
narrative ballet choreographers
that ever lived, Sir Frederick
Ashton and Sir Kenneth
MacMillan, creating works
for the Royal Ballet.
So I grew up in that
world, like Leanne,
and then I moved
to New York when
I was 19 because I wanted
something different.
And I'd had a chance to dance in
a ballet by George Balanchine.
And it was the first
time, it was liberating.
It was for my school
performance in London.
Suddenly I was just
kind of thrust out
onto the stage, and just
really devouring space,
and it was the music
that was driving me.
There wasn't a story.
It was just really purely about
sort of an emotional response
to music.
So that encouraged me
to move to New York,
and I built my
choreographic career
really learning from the inside
of these great Balanchine
and Robbins works, and the
works also of Jerome Robbins.
So having the chance to kind of
bring those two worlds together
and put them on the stage
in this beautiful show,
I feel like I was
able to really draw
from both of those experiences.
ROBERT FAIRCHILD: I
feel like for me, it's
been whar-- I've had
the opportunity three
times in the past two weeks to
go dance back with the New York
City Ballet, because that
was kind of the deal.
My boss said, well, I'll let
you go on Broadway for a year
if you come back and dance
for me every once in awhile.
So I had three
shows, and honestly,
what I've learned from doing
Broadway and this show,
and telling stories,
has informed everything
about my dancing in a
completely different way.
I go back on that stage,
and my thought process
is completely different.
Whether there's a
story or there's not,
there's something
happening in my brain.
There's something
being told, and I
think that's why ballet can
become unrelatable sometimes,
is because people
don't relate themselves
to who they are in
the moment, as people,
and put that into their dancing.
And when we get to
do that in the show,
the dance is a real part
of the storytelling.
It's these people, when words
can't describe your feeling,
song can't describe your
feeling, but movement does.
And that's something
so incredible to get
to learn through this
show, and then, to bring
that back to New York
City Ballet, and just
kind of permeate that world
with what we're doing,
is just so incredible.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
I'm looking forward
to seeing the show,
and I'm looking forward to
having you back in ballet.
STUART OKEN: Not so fast!
FEMALE SPEAKER: Well,
this has been fantastic.
I've been, personally,
very excited.
Everyone here in the
audience has been very
excited to have you guys here.
Guys, "An American in Paris" is
showing at the Palace Theater.
That's 1564 Broadway, on the
corner of Broadway and 47th
Street here in New York City.
If you want more
information about the show,
you should check
out their website,
anamericaninparisbroadway.com.
American No spaces.
Guys, thank you so much.
Can we give them
another hand, please?
[INAUDIBLE]